cherry ya une émission qu'on adore ses
affaires conclues qui cartonne sur
france 2 tous les jours et vous avez été
nombreux à nous demander le retour de
chou qui vous souvenez que mokhtar et
john eledjam l'excellente via mail et
diane avait déjà piégé samuel etienne
dans questions pour un champion pour la
grande race rade et voilà c'est le
retour de chouki mokhtar ans ou qui
c'est on retourne provoqua un efi cette
fois ci tu as été piégé sophie davant
avec donc john eledjam
alors je vous le dis si encore la folie
sophie davant merci elle merci à la
production d'affaires conclut regarder
et regardez ce qu'ils ont été brandis
c'est parti
[Musique]
découvrons maintenant ce que les deux
amis d'enfance chou qui est signée honte
à vous proposer à la vente nous vendre
un objet un peu spécial qui est son père
de ma bouche alors ce sont des babouches
qui ont appartenu à rami 16,2 au roi du
maroc et la chope calais le champion on
est venu ici parce qu'on espère faire
une affaire conclue et brown en dessous
puis bonjour brochure vous débat bouge
ton alors qu'ils échouent qui est si
mais choqué show qui estime que cette
visite dans la vie je suis chauffeur
hubert et j'ai aussi un bar à chicha qui
s'appelle le shisha beauté si j'avais
des gens le chat botté exactement tu es
un petit jeu de mot chéchar vous avez
saisi ne la vis
les habitants continuent c'est un drôle
de réserves en bons c'est que peut-être
oui merci je la tue un peu de stress
quand même
ah oui c'est le stress mais sept frères
non pas du tout je suis contrôleur de
gestion
ok voilà à l'heure des babouches à roll
des années j'avais passé départ je
n'avais jamais eu dans les bichons n'ai
pas eu beaucoup à l'expertisé non plus
elle aime tous ses babouches
on les a achetés dans un souk à un gerbe
à inquiéter pourquoi les vendez vos
oreilles en aidant besoin d'eux avait
plein d'oiseaux
alors donc une paire de babouches
il faut savoir que la babouche c'est un
soulier traditionnelle dans le monde
arabo-musulman et les premières babouche
remontent au 3e siècle après
jésus-christ combien à peu près à temps
de laisser moins forte cependant qu'au
moins mon expertise en tout cas c'est
une version citadine c'est une version
de fait on s'en fout entonnant où elle
se rend dans le souci de seconde
donc là nous avons un modèle un petit
peu plus attention pu travailler on a un
modèle un tout petit peu plus travaillé
donc avec avec une une ornementation de
fils d'or et des petits cabochons sané
diamant et de c'est ce sont des pierres
d'imitation c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
me dit gêné j'ai parlé ce jour là sinon
c'est combien sont métalliques
excusez moi et je vois que une des
babouches a été signé par chèque
le chanteur s'est servi activement le
chanteur tcheka des allèles riches à la
lutte contre moi je vous sens je ne sais
pas ce que je pensais que c'était bien
pour le ski ça joyent excusez moi
monsieur bompard était je ne souhaitais
pas agressif avec madame mais j'avais
vraiment vraiment et c'est donc vous les
vendez dans quel but
l'oseille
alors la roll's je vais vous proposer
une estimation de santoro donc sans
heureuse au tram à ses généraux santoro
non mais c'est quand même bien travaillé
vous savez c'est un travail de philippe
d'or parmi les 2 90 euros
voici le pass et voudrait absolument
femmes enfants sont ma bouche à vous de
sa rançon
la première suisse en salle des ventes
de tu commences à me casser les couilles
et vous réglez vos petits contes la
province ok merci beaucoup d'éleveurs si
arsenal suffit je suis pas un peu déçu
je suis très très déçu mais après j'ai
des trois mois j'ai un rapport non
vraiment je vais kent arras continue
j'adore ça c'est pas toi sont déjà en
train de faire passer pour des boulots
ça existe à mulhouse
quoi qu'il arrive moi j'ai besoin d'eux
a eu genre pas dit chez son argent et
surtout surtout en cash
big up à tout le monde arabe
[Musique]
dédicacé ou non les babouches de chou
qui est simon brandt elle séduire nos
acheteurs et dépasser les 100 euros
d'estimation de notre commissaire
priseur
on le découvre tout de suite
bonjour bonjour messieurs bonjour
abbas et direct vous lisiez les i c'est
pas grave je ne voyais même pas d'où
vous vous demandez comment vous avez
bien merci
c'est ce plan d'ici michel année
messieurs je m'appelle chouki et je
m'appelle simon et alors vous êtes
chacun venu avec une lampe d'aladin bush
délai d'un à bout modèle vous avez la
gauche ouais vous avez vu entre en
dessous chef khaled al est le chant
aouichaoui c'est ça les chats écoute de
tout bois comme cela 2-1 quand tout fait
de verre de cendrillon version marocaine
elle est ornée de diamants véritables de
tunisie ouais les diamants tunisien quoi
parlera du diamant
ces diamants mais alors racontez nous
comment se fait-il qu'elle soit signé
par khaled comment vous avez réussi avec
ça alors on les a achetés aux os ou de
gerba et en tunisie en tout cas voilà
dans cet univers là et elles ont été
portées donc pas ramsès ii et le roi du
maroc
ah oui en tout cas moi je voudrais en
profiter pour saluer tous nos amis du
maghreb qui nous regarde tous les jours
salom salam aleikoum aller comme ça chez
toujours pas de reprise
[Rires]
moi je me sers ce que vous faites dans
la vie parce que y'a un truc je suis
champion du val de marne de d'algèbre
très chic
merci beaucoup 85 au carré 35 au carré
absolument
[Musique]
je prie ses commentatrices on aimerait
faire une affaire conclue ce qui est
certain c'est que vous allez retrouver
votre argent b d'avion bouffe un julien
tu vas acheter acheter en espèces je
perds à bah ouais là je crois que c'est
ce qui me concerne moi c'est plus chèque
devant que je connais un peu le monde de
la télé c'est un peu magouille et
compagnie du coup chèque de banque de
préférence c'est possible apparition à
part du brickyard
alors moi je vais commencer à a3
ressortent france au début ça mais on
laisse monter les enchères les bulles ça
peut se chauffer sont très sales à
l'intérieur où il sans vouloir manquer
de respect à sa majesté ramsès ii je
pense que c'est la lose lose et vas-y là
de parler
qu'est ce qu'il fait lui non il est
contrarié on peut continuer les enchères
ça ne vous dérange pas excusez moi pour
venu pour ça leur manquer de respect à
les 20 25 si tu veux 30 juin les
bouquets parle de parler tout le temps
alors si on peut remplacer mais j'espère
pouvoir enchaîner
quand tu me l'as les gens le prix là on
n'est pas des guignols non mais quelle
date on n'est pas des guignols on peut
savoir maintenant des chutes à l'heure
est maintenant à la v2 vivre l'âme à
leur sélection à 8,8 euros l'attitude
fait pas celle en fait satisfait je
pense qu'il va falloir vous séparer un
moment donné parce que ça va se terminer
très mal parce qu'on fait à ma bouche
gauche la partie m tu fais parce que cam
ward
c'est attendait ce moment où voilà enfin
démissionner là et nous on est on est
pour la paix sérieux on est pour la
personne
on vient les récupérer de l'argent tu
fais comme ça le bouffon cherchant vous
êtes nouveau genre de là j'avoue je n'ai
pas aussi baissait de la porte vous
avouer nous sommes cgc mokhtar mme
l'émission de cyril hanouna pour la
grande race sera numéro 4 merci beaucoup
en tout cas merci
[Applaudissements]
quand
c'est l'inversé tous les deux là bas
personne et toute son équipe
toute l'équipe a manqué d amour avec la
production je vais lire merci encore
emerse voilà ils sont super voilà c'est
d amour et merci à eux et sophie elle
est allée génial voilée au début vous
avez vu comme elle est sympathique et sa
fille allegra dans la vie il jouit
permis on roulait vers la rive en replay
de mokhtar et john regarder parce
qu'elle est animal découvrons maintenant
ce que les deux amis d'enfance chouki et
simon honte à nous proposait à la vente
nous sommes venus rendre un objet est ce
qu'à un moment tu as senti qu'ils
s'étaient doutés notre crois pas le jury
parce que c'est son nom wallace et
sociaux mais on a vu qu'on commettait en
coulisses ouais voilà la sortie no doubt
a reconnu mais tu es magnifique comme ça
et mokhtar excellent comédien john a
[Applaudissements]